I love talking and conversing with you
but I can't hear you though because the
music is so loud so do you want to go
outside and talk more yeah so are you
sure you know why not let's do it I
haven't conversed in ages okay
it's been 10 years since I movie people
even what a trip what would you tell
that girl who started super bad knowing
what you know now how lucky are you yeah
yes it's been a decade since this moment
of a cinematic history went down what's
wrong
um I would prefer if we just do that at
him at some other time that was so much
fun we were we were like it was like
4:00 a.m. because it was a night shoot
and we had just been up for hours and we
had to do the kissing scene we did it
all kinds of different ways it's like me
just standing there him leaning in and
me not pushing him off and just bigger
and him kissing me for a really
awkwardly long time with me not kissing
back just like not knowing what to do
and then worse I can be pushing him off
and all kinds of different all kinds of
different of course et was with the then
18 year old Emma in 2007 to talk her big
screen debut made it through a few takes
clear but um yeah they probably just
took those single tanks and put them in
the movies there's a fun the only time
that wasn't laughing so so I'm glad that
I could keep your faces for was just
like night
you